du jour appelle la discussion de la
proposition loi visant à abolir la
corrida un petit pas pour l'animal un
grand pas pour l'humanité la parole est
à Monsieur aymeric Caron rapporteur de
la commission des lois de
constitutionnelles de la législation et
de l'administration générale de la
République pour une durée de 10 minutes
maximum
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je vois rien ah oui je veux bien que
oui merci
[Applaudissements]
que j'ai l'honneur de vous soumettre
interroge le plus profond de nos
consciences
longtemps nous avons maltraité les
animaux sans le moindre remords et puis
au 19e siècle les premières lois de
protection animale ont été adoptées en
Angleterre et en France et puis depuis
ce moment ces lois sont en permanence
interrogées réactualisées améliorer en
fonction de l'évolution de nos standards
moraux et de nos connaissances
désormais dans notre pays les sévices
sur les animaux
peuvent être punies de 5 ans de prisons
et de 75000 euros d'amende
je crois que nous pouvons être fiers
de ces dispositions qui actent que notre
République ne tolère pas les violences
inutiles sur les animaux
ce principe est un fondement dont toutes
les conséquences n'ont pas encore été
tirées mais la mérite d'exister de
servir de socle aux réflexions que nous
menons sur nos relations avec les autres
espèces
et ce que je vous demande aujourd'hui
chers collègues
c'est simplement de réparer une
injustice
car malgré la volonté claire du
législateur il y a encore des endroits
en France où l'on peut torturer et tuer
un animal pour le plaisir et ce en
raison d'une exception accordée au
prétexte d'une pratique traditionnelle
locale
ininterrompu vous voyez c'est aberrant
mais la même cérémonie de maltraitance
animale interdite à Paris à Nantes à
Strasbourg est autorisé à Béziers ou à
Nîmes comment tolérer encore aujourd'hui
cette incohérence qui permet à des
corridas de se tenir dans certaines
villes françaises alors qu'elles sont
interdites par la loi commune
c'est précisément cette aberration
législative que nous devons faire
disparaître car les sévices sur les
animaux ne sont acceptables nulle part
dans notre République
une et indivisible ils ne sont
acceptables nulle part dans un pays qui
se veut phare en matière de droits
humains et de respect du vivant
alors certains prétendent que le taureau
ne souffre pas dans la reine
ils expliquent que l'excitation liée à
la lutte face au torero et les
caractéristiques génétiques de l'animal
le Premier ministre de toute inconfort
j'ai même entendu de la part de certains
afficionados que le taureau tirait une
certaine fierté de sa mise à mort
chorégraphiée
je doute sérieusement de ce dernier
point par refus d'anthropomorphisme mais
par respect pour la science je ne peux
raisonnablement prêter au taureau des
sentiments qui ne sont que des prétextes
pour mieux la servir l'humilier
et le torturer en bonne conscience oui
Jean-Paul mot torture ce n'est pas de la
provocation
croyez bien chers collègues
mais je ne vois pas d'autres mots à
utiliser
pendant les 20 minutes que durent sont
calvaire le taureau subit des coups de
piques dont la pointe peut s'enfoncer
jusqu'à 30 cm dans l'échelle
7 pics coupe blesse mutilent les muscles
les tendons les ligaments les nerfs
cette pique a pour objet paraît-il de
montrer la bravoure du taureau elle sert
surtout à l'affaiblir en s'attaquant
ligament du coup ce qui empêchera
l'animal ensuite de lever la tête pour
se défendre on plante ensuite dans son
dos des banderies terminées par un
harpon en acier de 6 cm harpon qui va
s'insérer dans l'échelle et les
travailler à chaque mouvement de
l'animal afin de le faire souffrir et de
l'affaiblir encore puis une fois que le
taureau est épuisé percute douleur vient
le moment de la mise à mort qui ne sera
pas immédiate
car on achève l'animal à l'épée mais
pour être fatale ou presque l'épée doit
transpercer le corps à un endroit et
sous un angle bien précis sinon le coût
ravage mais laisse en vie le matador
rate souvent son coup et doit s'y
reprendre si le taureau met encore trop
longtemps à tomber si il est couche
arcute sans tuer on utilise une autre
épée d'un autre format et on recommence
l'opération pendant ce temps le taureau
suffoque dans son sang qu'il vomit
lorsqu'il se couche enfin le taureau
n'est pas encore mort on va donc
l'achever avec un couteau planté
derrière la tête par petit coup vous
verrez des toreros frapper la tête du
taureau à 4 5 ou 6 reprises
s'acharner presque désespérément parce
que l'animal ne veut pas ou n'arrive pas
à mourir
ensuite on lui coupe les oreilles la
queue alors même qu'il n'est pas encore
tout à fait mort souvent est-ce qu'on
peut vraiment appeler ça de l'art comme
le font certains
moi je ne le crois pas
les défenseurs de la corrida convoquent
généralement Hemingway Picasso comme
argument d'autorité ils aimaient la
corrida donc la corrida c'est bien
moi je préfère citer Robert Badinter qui
disait il y a quelques semaines
la corrida est une des expressions de la
culture du sang et de la mort ce ne sera
jamais la mienne
[Applaudissements]
chers collègues nous pouvons choisir
d'abolir la corrida aujourd'hui
mais certains d'entre vous
ont préféré refuser le débat et empêcher
le vote plus de 800 amendements étaient
déposés et il est pour le moment
impossible de mener à bien un travail
parlementaire constructif impossible
d'arriver au vote finale dans les délais
impartis c'est à dire minuit
[Applaudissements]
c'est ainsi que vous voyez la démocratie
s'il vous plaît chers collègues seul
monsieur le rapporteur à la parole
poursuivez
c'est pourquoi je vous demande chers
collègues parce que les Français
attendent énormément de nous aujourd'hui
parce qu'il nous servent
je vous demande de retirer tous les
amendements d'obstruction pour laisser
la possibilité au vote
pour permettre une décision historique
pour les droits des animaux mais aussi
pour l'expression de notre humanité je
vous remercie
je vous remercie
la parole est à Madame Dominique fort
secrétaire des tâches chargés de la
ruralité
[Applaudissements]
merci madame la Présidente ce monsieur
le Président de la Commission monsieur
le rapporteur mesdames et messieurs les
députés aujourd'hui nous sommes réunis
autour d'une proposition de loi du
député Caron dans le cadre de la niche
parlementaire de la France insoumise
visant à abolir la corrida sur
l'ensemble de notre territoire mesdames
et messieurs les députés je veux tout
d'abord rappeler devant vous et pour la
bonne tenue de nos débats que le
gouvernement que je représente
aujourd'hui a une parfaite conscience de
la complexité des discussions que nous
serons amenés à avoir ensemble la
corrida renvoie chacun à son intimité la
plus profonde à son rapport à l'animal
et à la mort c'est un sujet qui traverse
toute la société tout un pays du nord au
sud qui traverse les générations et qui
traversent aussi la quasi-totalité des
groupes politiques de notre Assemblée
nationale qui observeront pour beaucoup
une liberté de vote sur ce texte
ce rapport à l'intime fait de la corrida
un sujet sur lequel chacun exprime sa
propre sensibilité je ne peux que
comprendre et ne pas rester insensible à
ceux pour qui le fait de voir un taureau
blessé par des banderies luttant jusqu'à
l'agonie pour ne pas succomber est
insoutenable il faut respecter cette
émotion et je ne pourrais jamais dire
que celle-ci n'est pas légitime ou
sincère mais je comprends aussi
l'émotion qui saisit les habitants des
villes dans le cœur bat au rythme de ces
feria au rythme de ces corridas
culturellement ancré dans les
territoires à l'idée qu'elle pourrait
être interdite c'est corridas dans
plusieurs villes du sud de la France
sont le fruit d'un véritable engouement
populaire qui pendant une semaine font
vibrer et adhérer toute une population à
une culture ancestrale qui relie chaque
territoire à son histoire
il ne faut jamais perdre de vue le rôle
social de ces feria
héritage qui se transmet de génération
en génération ces deux émissions pardon
ces deux émotions il faut les respecter
et je pense qu'elle ne doivent pas
s'opposer le gouvernement est animé par
la défense du bien-être animal tout
d'abord je veux vous assurer à quel
point les enjeux de la cause animale mis
en avant par ceux qui voudraient voir la
corrida CC sont au coeur de nos
préoccupations le gouvernement et la
majorité ont été à l'initiative au cours
du mandat précédent d'avancer notable
pour le bien-être animal témoignant de
l'importance que nous donnons à ce sujet
nous sommes la majorité qui a le plus
agi ces dernières années sur le
bien-être animal notamment en votant la
loi du 30 novembre 2021 certains d'entre
vous doivent s'en souvenir visant à
lutter contre la maltraitance animale et
a renforcer le lien entre les animaux et
les hommes suite à la proposition de
l'ex député de la majorité Loïc
d'ombreval
à travers ce texte nous avons renforcé
l'ensemble des sacs des sanctions en cas
de maltraitance animale et nous en
sommes fiers nous avons interdit à
partir de 2026 les spectacles d'orques
et de dauphins et d'ici 2028 la
détention et le spectacle d'animaux
sauvages dans les cirques itinérants
l'action du gouvernement ne s'est pas
limité à cette loi par un décret du 6
février 2022 il s'est engagé à mettre un
terme aux broyage des poussins mâles
dans la filière des poules pondeuses on
parlait alors de 50 millions de poussins
broyés chaque année voici des exemples
concrets de nos actions pour soutenir la
cause animale vous le voyez le
gouvernement et notre majorité non pas
attendu monsieur le député Caron pour
être responsable et acteur du bien-être
animal aujourd'hui je suis fier de
porter la parole d'un gouvernement et
d'une majorité qui sur le sujet du
bien-être animal ont agi en
responsabilité et sont même aller plus
loin que certains de nos voisins nous
continuerons à agir dans ce sens mais
de notre côté comme la préciser la cour
d'appel de Toulouse il ne saurait être
contesté que dans le midi de la France
entre le Pays d'Art et le Pays Basque
entre garrigues et Méditerranée entre
Pyrénées et Garonne en Provence
Languedoc Catalogne Gascogne Land et
Pays Basque il existe une très forte
tradition taurine qui se manifeste par
l'organisation de corrida de manière
régulière en effet cette pratique est à
ce jour autorisée dans une cinquantaine
de communes de notre pays par dérogation
à l'article 521-1 du code pénal au nom
d'une tradition locale ininterrompue
elle est par exemple documentée depuis
1289 à Bayonne cela signifie mesdames et
messieurs les députés que nous discutons
aujourd'hui d'une pratique et d'ores et
déjà interdite dans plus de 35000
communes qui n'ont pas de passé intime
avec la corrida et l'on ne peut que s'en
réjouir
pourquoi je suis attaché à ne pas abolir
la corrida aujourd'hui
si on trouve à première vue la corrida
barbares j'aimerais face à vous aussi
défendre ce qu'est la porte à nos
territoires que ce soit pour en garantir
la diversité pour y incarner une preuve
de liberté et pour alimenter en leur
sein une filière économique majeure
tout d'abord devant vous au-delà de la
corrida je voudrais défendre la
diversité de nos territoires et la
pluralité de notre société diversité à
laquelle vous le savez je suis
particulièrement attaché la corrida est
une tradition ancestrale dans notre pays
qui participe à l'identité de certains
territoires des enfants qui dès l'école
primaire visitent les ganadélias dans
les Landes des défilés de gardien à
Arles en passant par la valorisation du
patrimoine aux Arènes de Nîmes sans la
tauromachie ces territoires perdraient
leur singularité voulons-nous condamner
des villes comme Dax Mont-de-Marsan ou
encore Vic faisant ça à disparaître de
notre imaginaire collectif je ne suis
pas ici juge pour décider ou non du
caractère désuet ou un acronique de la
corrida par contre je peux témoigner de
la place que cette tradition
occupe dans nos territoires alors bien
sûr me direz-vous
les feria survivront certainement la
suppression des corridas mais ce que je
tenais à illustrer ici c'est la place
que la corrida occupe dans certains de
nos territoires et j'en suis certaine
pas plus que Monsieur Caron ne souhaite
stigmatiser toute la moitié sud de notre
pays je ne souhaite surtout pas
stigmatiser un député parisien qui
éloigné de toute considération politique
ne serait animé que par des convictions
profondes sur le bien-être animal
je voudrais ensuite défendre la liberté
de chacun d'assister ou non à une
corrida la liberté le sujet ici n'est
pas tant de savoir si la corrida doit
mourir de sa belle-mère ou si elle doit
être condamnée par notre assemblée mais
plutôt de garantir le lit Barbie de tout
un chacun face à cette pratique la
proposition de loi telle qu'elle est
défendue représente un texte de
restriction de cette liberté qui ne
porte préjudice à aucun être humain nous
sommes dans cette hémicycle tout
s'attacher aux libertés individuelles la
ferveur autour de la corrida a toujours
fluctué avec les époques avec l'histoire
d'une centaine de corrides d'apparents
il y a 10 ans aujourd'hui seulement une
cinquantaine de corridas se déroulent
dans l'Hexagone et puis troisièmement je
veux défendre devant vous une filière
pour laquelle les conséquences d'une
adoption du texte serait demain
irrémédiable et désastreuse au-delà
d'une tradition elle représente un tissu
économique non négligeable qui a été
d'ores et déjà lourdement affecté par la
crise sanitaire du covid 19 la corrida
c'est une cinquantaine d'élevages dans
les régions Occitanie provençal le
peu-côte d'Azur et nouvelle Aquitaine
c'est une filière d'excellence la race
brave qui est reconnue comme une race
locale et comme une race menacée en
France elle participe à la biodiversité
à l'entretien de certains de nos
paysages comme en Camargue par exemple
comment aujourd'hui pourrait-on dans
cette émission décider de l'avenir de
cette filière sans avoir pris le temps
de les écouter ces acteurs de cette
filière et sans avoir imaginé un
programme d'accompagnement et de
reconversion pour toutes celles et ceux
qui vivent
de la tauromachie avant nous seulement
une étude d'impact pour mesurer ces
éléments et puis enfin il n'y a pas
d'urgence sur ce sujet
en temps de crise je crois profondément
que l'essentiel est de ne pas fracturer
le pays il est contre-productif
d'opposer les français à des fins qui
semblent plus politiques qu'essentiel
face au moment tumultueux que nous
traversons essayons plutôt de nous
écouter les uns les autres de nous
respecter et de faire preuve de
tolérance j'ai effectué un grand nombre
de déplacements depuis ma nomination et
s'il y a une chose dont je suis sûr
c'est qu'ici dans cette hémicycle nous
sommes tous convaincus que les
Françaises et les Français ont
aujourd'hui bien d'autres préoccupations
les réelles urgences celles des Français
c'est le pouvoir d'achat c'est la hausse
du coût de l'énergie c'est la situation
de guerre en Europe c'est le manque de
médecins dans nos campagnes c'est
l'urgence climatique c'est la gestion de
l'eau voilà cher dép ce qui je le crois
préoccupe nos concitoyens et devraient
occuper nos débats
la question que nous devons finalement
nous poser aujourd'hui et voulons-nous
une France monochrome une France
uniforme voulons-nous une société de
l'interdiction ou préférons-nous une
France plurielle respectueuse de
l'histoire et des traditions de chacun
de ces territoires votez pour la
proposition telle qu'elle est formulée
aujourd'hui dans l'urgence ce n'est ni à
porter une solution à nos concitoyens ni
résoudre quoi que ce soit dans les
oppositions qui traversent notre société
sur ce sujet c'est enlever de la liberté
à une partie de nos concitoyens pour
terminer en rappelant l'essentiel la loi
en vigueur aujourd'hui permet par
dérogation seul territoire de tradition
taurine d'organiser des corridas et
empêche tous les territoires qui
souhaiteraient développer de nouvelles
corrida de le faire cette loi existante
en France elle est respectueuse de nos
différences
je vous invite donc mesdames et
messieurs les députés à voter contre
cette proposition de loi portée par le
député la France insoumise aymeric Caron
je vous remercie
merci madame la ministre
nous en venons à la discussion générale
la parole est à Madame Anne stand back
Ternois pour le groupe la France
insoumise et pour une durée de 10
minutes
[Applaudissements]
madame la présidente madame la ministre
monsieur le rapporteur chers collègues
je voudrais vous dire d'abord mon
émotion à prendre la parole devant vous
en ce moment historique pour défendre
l'abolition de la corrida
samedi dernier lors d'une manifestation
en soutien à cette proposition de loi
j'ai entendu le témoignage d'une petite
fille elle disait son incompréhension
devant ce spectacle de douleur sans nom
qu'elle a corrida elle formait le vœu
que les adultes écoute parfois plus le
bon sens des enfants et je ne vous cache
pas qu'elle m'a rappelé une autre petite
fille qui ne comprenait pas non plus que
son pays permet tant d'inhumanité dans
les arènes tant de violence sur un
animal cette petite fille ne se doutait
pas qu'elle aurait un jour la chance de
monter à la tribune de l'Assemblée
nationale pour essayer de convaincre ses
collègues députés de mettre enfin un
terme à cette aberration
car ce jour est arrivé enfin la question
de l'abolition de la corrida est portée
dans l'hémicycle enfin nous avons
l'occasion ensemble de réparer ce qui
n'est rien d'autre qu'une erreur
tragique de notre droit
en 1853 l'empereur Napoléon III pour les
beaux yeux de son épouse Eugénie
importait la corrida d'Espagne sur le
sol français cela au mépris de la loi de
notre pays car oui la première loi de
protection des animaux en France avait
été promulgués trois ans plus tôt
c'était la loi Grammont du nom de ce
général ému des mauvais traitements
faits aux chevaux dans les rues de Paris
cette loi interdisait tout acte de
cruauté envers un animal domestique en
public la corrida a donc toujours été
illégal décédé
mais on l'a laissé prospérer pour
complaire à la couronne impériale à tel
point qu'au lieu de sévir de faire
appliquer la loi comme la raison le
commandait on a fini 5 ans plus tard par
à l'inverse adapter la loi au crime en
accordant une dérogation pour la corrida
et aujourd'hui encore il est donc
possible de torturer un animal en France
dès lors qu'il s'agit d'un taureau dans
les arènes de quelques villes du sud de
la France on ne parle pas de petites
souffrances ici pendant la corrida le
taureau est transpercé de part en part
d'abord par la pique du picador puis par
les banderies qui porte un joli nom
ensoleillé mais sont en fait des harpons
qui s'agrippent dans la chair puis
viennent les épées et le couteau enfin
pour le coup de grâce enfin je devrais
plutôt dire les coups de grâce puisque
bien souvent il faut s'y reprendre à
plusieurs fois
l'animal vacille tremble aveuglé par le
sang il tombe puis se relève dans la
douleur parfois même il vomit du sang
mais qui peut dire s'enciller qu'il ne
souffre pas
s'il en était besoin l'ordre national
des vétérinaires là de toute façon
affirmé sans hésitation dans un rapport
de 2016 oui le taureau souffre pendant
la corrida et ni la sélection génétique
ni les conditions d'élevage ni font rien
cette pratique est tout simplement
parfaitement incompatible avec toute
notion de bien-être animal
mes chers collègues je vais maintenant
vous demander un petit effort
d'imagination regardez-le ce taureau
c'est la fin du tercio il a subi tous
les coups il vit sur le sable espérant
le couteau final pour que ces
souffrances cesse et bien maintenant ce
n'est plus un taureau c'est votre chien
vous le voyez vous le voyez agonisant
terrorisé ensanglanté avec les banderies
plantées dans le dos ne comprenant pas
pourquoi la main de l'homme l'a frappé
le vent vers vous ses yeux implorants
demandant grâce vous le voyez là vous le
voyez le problème maintenant l'erreur
fondamentale
comment accepter pour un taureau ce que
tout le monde instinctivement trouve
insupportable pour un chien
collègue de renaissance
l'an dernier s'il vous plaît chers
collègues on ne s'interpelle pas seul
l'oratrice à la parole s'il vous plaît
je vous remercie collègue de renaissance
l'an dernier presque à la même date vous
votiez fièrement une loi vivante je cite
à lutter contre la maltraitance animale
et conforter le lien entre les animaux
et les hommes conforter le lien entre
les animaux et les hommes c'est bien de
cela qu'il s'agit aujourd'hui c'est de
notre lien aux animaux au vivant que
nous parlons je cite ici l'explorateur
et naturaliste Théodore Monod la corrida
et le symbole cruel de la servissement
de la nature par l'homme tout est dit
nul notion de subsistance ou de
nécessité d'aucune sorte pendant la
corrida le taureau est traité en objet
dont on peut disposer il souffre et
meurt pour notre bon plaisir pour notre
divertissement quel meilleur allégorie
d'une domination totale
mais aujourd'hui nous le savons nous le
savons il faut en finir avec ce
comportement dominateur et destructeur
nous apporteons tous au même monde du
vivant nous partageons avec les animaux
le seul écosystème qui nous soit vivable
nos destins sont liés et en réalité nous
avons déjà tranché cette question notre
code pénal est formel il est interdit de
faire souffrir un animal volontairement
plus encore de le tuer par conséquent si
vous vous amusez à torturer et tuer un
taureau en place publique à Brest par
exemple ou bien si vous plantez un coup
d'épée entre les omoplates de votre
lapin nain n’importe où en France vous
serez coupable d'un délit et passible de
5 ans d'emprisonnement et de 75000 euros
d'amende
ce ne sont pas de petites peines
mais le même comportement au dépôt d'un
taureau au sein d'une arène dans le sud
de la France ce serait sans conséquence
pour paraphraser une célèbre chanson
est-ce que ce monde est sérieux
on ne peut pas on ne peut plus se draper
dans l'idée de tradition pour défendre
cela les traditions ne sont pas
immuables elles évoluent avec les
sociétés et c'est heureux il fut un
temps où les Français émettent à
assister aux exécutions publiques
c'était un divertissement familial prisé
je ne pense pas que quiconque ici pleure
ce temps là
nous ne sommes plus au 19e siècle
aujourd'hui nous reconnaissons tous les
animaux comme des êtres sensibles et
capables de ressentir la douleur c'est
même écrit noir sur blanc dans notre
code rural à l'article L214 dans notre
Code civil à l'article 515-14 les
animaux sont des êtres sensibles et
doivent être traités comme tel
prenons exemple sur la Catalogne qui fut
une place forte mondiale de la Toro
Massie et qui pourtant a mis fin à la
corrida il y a 10 ans déjà
nous pouvons défendre notre additions
mais pas la violence pas la violence pas
en 2022 ce n'est plus possible
enfin chers collègues du Sud dont je
suis soyez raisonnable vous le savez
aujourd'hui la feria n'est absolument
plus synonyme de corrida mettre fin à la
violence dans les arènes ne signera pas
la fin de la fête nous continuerons à
danser au son des bandas à chanter
Paquito de chocolaté ou les fêtes de
moléons as-tu tête les jeux les
festivités les tournois en tout genre
continueront de nous égayer et la joie
la sangria et la convivialité seront
toujours de la partie
mais comme finalement pour l'immense
majorité des Français qui viennent au
feria aujourd'hui pour la fête en
elle-même sans jamais mettre un pied
dans l'arène il ne sera simplement plus
question de nous amuser autour d'une
tombe alors aujourd'hui ensemble nous
pouvons aller résolument dans le sens de
l'histoire toutefois certains de nos
collègues s'y refusent au total plus de
800 amendements ont été déposés sur
cette proposition de loi avec un article
unique
373 amendements pour les députés du
rassemblement national qui pourtant se
font passer pour des défenseurs des
animaux 117 pour certains députés
Renaissance sans compter l'aide de
quelques non inscrits c'est kyrielles
d'amendement ridicule que certains ont
déposé par paquet de sang sur ce texte
sont une insulte à l'attente exprimée
par la société
est-ce que vraiment on grandit le débat
en proposant ironiquement de former les
toreros au bien-être animal ou en
s'interrogeant sur la température
extérieure idéale pour torturer un
taureau
la France se souviendra de votre
attitude puéril et criminel
l'organisation des débats se fait avec
vous ici mais rappelons-nous que le pays
est avec nous la population est
majoritairement opposée à la corrida et
ce même dans les terres dites taurines
on y aime les courses de vachette bonne
enfant oui beaucoup moins les corridas
avec mise à mort
selon un sondage Ifop de février dernier
87% de nos concitoyens souhaitent la fin
de cette dérogation au code pénal
qu'elle a corrida à ce niveau là c'est
une exigence démocratique qui nous est
faite et que quelques-uns piétinent
aujourd'hui
or nous sommes les élus du peuple les
représentants de la nation nous nous
devons de les entendre nous devons
affirmer que nul l'animal ne peut plus
subir d'acte de cruauté dans notre pays
sans exception alors qu'on se le dise ce
que vous faites aujourd'hui par un
simple mécanisme mesquin d'obstruction
parlementaire ces perpétuer des actes de
torture sur des animaux rien d'autre
je conclus avec ces mots de Marguerite
Yourcenar l'homme a peu de chance de
cesser d'être un tortionnaire pour
l'homme tant qu'il continuera à
apprendre sur la bête son métier de
bourreau je vous remercie
je vous remercie
monsieur le rapporteur vous avez demandé
la parole
[Applaudissements]
collègues
j'ai beaucoup entendu parler de courage
depuis trois mois
depuis les trois mois que je travaille
avec le groupe de la France insoumise
à ce projet d'en finir avec cette
torture qui est la corrida en France je
regrette de n'en voir pas beaucoup de
courage dans cette émission à ce moment
précis je vois
je vois je vois pas mal de l'acheter
chez certains d'entre vous s'il vous
plaît
dans la manière que vous avez décidé de
fuir le débat
dans la manière que vous avez
de tout faire pour refuser le vote le
vote qui vous donnerait tort
dans votre manière de tout faire pour
pas donner satisfaction 87 % de procès
qui aujourd'hui réclame la police de la
corrida en France
je vous ai demandé tout à l'heure
si vous pouviez être à la hauteur de
votre mandat en permettant la tenue d'un
débat digne sur ce sujet
en retirant tous les amendements
d'obstruction au moment où je parle
aucun d'entre eux n'a été retiré
il reste plus de 80 il reste plus de 480
amendements à étudier avec un rythme de
20 amendements à l'heure ça représente
24 heures de débat bien sûr vous l'avez
fait pour la qualité des échanges
monsieur le rapporteur s'il vous plaît
je demande quelques instants s'il vous
plaît chers collègues merci bien vouloir
écouter rapporteur jusqu'au bout mais
sur la porteur si vous pouviez aller au
fait de votre réaction
[Applaudissements]
je veux quand même car les Français nous
regardent je veux quand même leur donner
des exemples des amendements que vous
avez déposés pour que nous puissions pas
travailler aujourd'hui
amendement pour former un taureau sur le
bien-être animal
un moment pour maintenir la corrida en
prévoyant une piqûre contre la douleur
[Applaudissements]
amendement pour que les corridas ne
puissent pas se dérouler lorsqu'il fait
plus de 40 degrés à l'extérieur voilà
comment vous travaillez il faut que les
Français soient au courant
à cet instant à cet instant je pense à
tous les Français qui attendaient
tellement de cette journée
je pense
à ces millions de Françaises et de
Français qui se sont mobilisés avec un
espoir qu'enfin on en finit avec cette
exception intolérable et indigne de
notre pays
je pense
je pense au dizaines d'associations qui
se sont mobilisés
et pour lesquelles ce jour était un jour
historique
[Musique]
je n'ose imaginer ce que toutes ces
personnes pensent pendant qu'elle nous
observent à l'instant même
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est une évidence
l'insulte l'insulte
s'il vous plaît
[Applaudissements]
c'est une évidence ça me coûte ça me
coûte de le reconnaître
oui ça me nave
et je tiens je tiens à m'en excuser
je tiens à mon excuser auprès de celles
et ceux qui ont tellement compté sur
nous
pour obtenir une victoire historique
mais je dois bien je dois bien me
résoudre je dois bien me rendre à
l'évidence nous ne pourrons pas abolir
la corrida en France aujourd'hui
applaudissez soyez fiers de vous
[Applaudissements]
je tiens à rassurer celles et ceux qui
nous écoutent
ce qui vient de se passer aujourd'hui
ce qui
[Musique]
vient de se passer aujourd'hui
n'est pas une fin si on est un peu à la
télé madame sachez qu'on nous regarde
sachez que les Français peuvent voir ce
qui se passe dans cette émission et je
les invite à regarder ce qui se passe
ici
journaliste oui c'est un métier honteux
c'est ça que je voulais dire c'est une
adjectif pour vous député député qui
essaye de faire passer des lois pour le
bien des français
s'il vous plaît
qui se passe aujourd'hui n'est pas une
fin mais ce n'est qu'un début
[Applaudissements]
ce qui se passe aujourd'hui n'est pas
une fin ce n'est qu'un début avec mes
collègues de la France insoumise je vais
déposer une nouvelle proposition de loi
une loi transpartisane
qui sera inscrite à nos débats dans le
cadre d'une semaine de l'assemblée
et j'invite tous mes collègues de tous
les groupes parce que je sais que vous
êtes nombreux et nombreuses dans chaque
groupe à vouloir la fin de la corrida je
vous invite chers collègues est-ce que
nous travaillons ensemble pour avoir une
victoire collective qu'attendent de nous
tous les Français et les Français
la corrida sera bientôt abolie dans ce
pays je le promets nous le promettons
[Applaudissements]
madame la Présidente vous l'avez compris
pour aujourd'hui malheureusement je suis
contraint contre un de retirer ce texte
[Applaudissements]
nous allons nous allons retrouver un
podcast chers collègues à la suite de la
déclaration du rapporteur ils ont donc
pris acte du retrait de la proposition
de loi par son auteur en application
s'il vous plaît s'il vous plaît je vais
aller au bout et je donnerai ensuite la
parole à Monsieur Olivier qui l'a
demandé puis à Madame Ménard pour un
rappel au règlement mais je vous prierai
bien vouloir écouter la suite il est
pris acte du retrait de la proposition
de loi par son auteur en application
l'article 84 alignée à deux du règlement
et en conséquence il n'y a pas lieu de
poursuivre la discussion sur ce texte
monsieur le Président oublié vous
vouliez vous exprimer
[Applaudissements]
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
rapporteur vous aviez pris une décision
courageuse lorsque vous aviez inscrit un
texte un texte qui divise un texte qui
interroge et un texte qui met chacun
devant des responsabilités soit de
choisir d'abolir la corrida au prétexte
du bien-être animal soit de refuser au
motif que on souhaiterait protéger des
traditions ce texte il a été examiné en
commission des lois d'ailleurs un
administrateur où vous a été dédié pour
réaliser ce travail les services de la
Commission des lois ont fait un travail
important sur ce sujet les collègues
quel que soit leur opinion toute
respectable toutes
on travaillait produit des amendements
parfois je le dis avec une grande
transparence parfois dilatoire et
parfois les moments de trucs il
n'empêche que ces amendements de
struction vous vous y livrez aussi pour
ce qui concerne votre groupe assez
régulièrement il faut le reconnaître
j'ai pas terminé
je n'ai pas terminé maintenant mais non
vous avez posé un débat vous avez eu le
loisir de vous exprimer d'exposer vos
motifs le gouvernement monsieur Ollier
le gouvernement a eu l'occasion de
présenter sa position le groupe de la
France insoumise a eu l'occasion de dire
ce qu'il pensait de votre proposition
tous les inscrits à la discussion
générale aurait mérité de dire quel
était leur position y compris pour
connaître et pour faire connaître à nos
concitoyens quel était la position des
différents groupes et par transparence
chacun aurait su comment se positionne
des différents groupes de l'Assemblée
nationale et vous auriez eu une réponse
à la question que vous aviez posée de
même et si on va un petit peu plus loin
il y avait un amendement de suppression
un amendement 20 avant de suppression
mon coachton un amendement de
suppression qui par ailleurs avait été
adopté par la Commission on en pense ce
qu'on en veut pour ou contre
[Applaudissements]
si c'est amendement avait été examiné
chacun aurait pu par une position de
vote que vous n'auriez pas demandé que
vous n'auriez pas manqué de demander au
scrutin public par une position de vote
connaître la position de tous les
députés et y compris si c'était votre
but de dire qui s'oppose à l'abolition
de la corrida et chacun aurait pu
constater finalement la position des uns
et les autres et en responsabilité pour
ceux qui veulent l'abolir comme en
responsabilité pour ceux qui ne le
veulent pas donc moi je regrette
sincèrement que tout ce travail ait été
vain et que c'est clarification elle
n'est pas eu lieu et je le regrette et
je pense que vous avez fait finalement
un de bien peu de courage aujourd'hui
par rapport à tout celui que vous aviez
rassemblé jusqu'à lors
madame Ménard pour une pour un rappel au
Règlement sur quel fondement merci
madame la Présidente sur la base de
l'article 70 à Linéa 3
monsieur Caron a traité les députés qui
défendent la corrida de lâche et de
manquer de courage et donc il souhaite
retirer son texte avant que nous ayons
pu débattre moi je rejoins la provision
du président de la commission des lois
il y a des amendements de suppression je
rappelle que ces amendements de
suppressions ont été adoptés en
commission alors
allons jusqu'au bout de cette discussion
ça va durer quoi une heure on va pouvoir
se prononcer et nous souhaitons aller au
vote sur ces amendements de suppression
nous souhaitons aller au vote sur ses
amendements de suppression on veut voter
pour affirmer clairement notre position
nous défendons la corrida ici
contrairement à vous mais en faisant ce
que vous venez de faire monsieur Caron
c'est vous qui manquez singulièrement de
courage aujourd'hui
madame blanc pour une demande de rappel
au règlement merci madame la Présidente
sur la même base que notre collègue pour
la bonne tenue des débats monsieur le
rapporteur en vérité vous fuyez le débat
vous avez peur du débat parce que nous
avons débattu la semaine dernière en
commission des lois arguments contre
argument finalement pendant une semaine
les amendements de nos collègues les
députés qui se sont élevés contre votre
texte de loi ce sont fait invectiver
insulter ils s'en sont pris plein la
figure juste parce que vous ne vous ne
voulez pas que nous voulions exprimer un
autre avis le débit du déni de
démocratie auquel nous assistons et
scandaleux parce que vous coupez la
discussion générale juste avant que nous
puissions émettre un avis différent vous
laissez croire à tout le monde que seul
votre avis pourrait représenter les
Français et bien non aujourd'hui un
certain nombre de députés ont déposé des
amendements nous demandons simplement
les examiner entendre les arguments des
uns et des autres et que nous allions
jusqu'au vote pour voir véritablement si
vous êtes représentant des Français mais
la vérité c'est qu'en réalité la
commission des lois s'est exprimée et à
voter un amendement de suppression et
que vous avez peur une nouvelle fois que
votre texte soit mis en échec
mes chers collègues mes chers collègues
je ferai droit aux demandes de rappel
aux règlements une par groupe je vous
rappelle que le texte a été retiré cela
est atteint ne sert à rien de demander
le retour de la discussion des
amendements la parole est à Monsieur
Corbière
demande de rappel aux règlements sur
quel fondement
la bonne tenue des débats articles 12 je
voudrais juste indiquer une chose à tous
les collègues quel que soit votre groupe
nous parlons aujourd'hui dans le cadre
de la niche parlementaire de la France
insoumise
d'accord et alors dites-vous qui est
contraint comme tous les groupes
subiront aussi cette contrainte de
déposer des textes en commençant la
séance à 9 heures et en étant contraint
de terminer à minuit collègue
je le dis
regardez y compris pour le propre
travail parlementaire que vous voulez
faire que vous subirez cette contrainte
égard au fait que si désormais chaque
groupe lorsque vous présenterez vos
textes profite de l'occasion pour faire
une pluie d'amendements pour que vous ne
puissiez pas avancer sur vos textes
c'est tout notre travail quel que soit
le groupe dans lequel nous ces gens qui
est aujourd'hui altéré je dis donc que
la défense du parlementarisme la défense
des droits des parlementaires la défense
de cette limitation de cette journée
limitée auxquelles nous avons tous droit
doit être respecté par tous
premièrement donc monsieur le rap
monsieur le Président de la Commission
quand vous avez évoqué que nous avons
une fois notamment utilisez le un nombre
d'arguments significatif dans un texte
présenté par le gouvernement ce texte
n'était pas contraint par la limite
horaire auquel nous sommes contraires
aujourd'hui ça n'était pas pour bloquer
le débat ça l'était pour le rendre
encore plus long afin que nos
concitoyens soient encore plus instruit
de ce débat à partir de là
en défense de mon ami le rapporteur
Emery Caron je voudrais d'abord au nom
de notre groupe parce que je connais ces
convictions forgées le salut et répétez
ce qu'il a dit à ceux qui l'ont
interpellé en lui disant qu'il avait eu
qu'il s'était défilé ce qu'il vient de
vous dire c'est que le débat va
continuer c'est que le débat va être
enrichi du fait que dans tous les
groupes là où il y a des partisans de la
police
la parole est à Monsieur Mylène pour une
demande de rappel au règlement
sur quel bouton
je demande de m'écouter notre groupe n'a
pas fait d'embolie parlementaire donc je
pense que nous sommes à même de parler
sincèrement sur ce qui vient de se
passer je vous ai rencontré il y a trois
semaines de ça à côté à la buvette vous
m'avez demandé si je vote et votre texte
et je me souviens très bien de ce que je
vous ai répondu je vous ai dit mon
opinion n'était pas faite parce qu'entre
la culture et la cruauté c'est vrai que
sur le moment j'ai du mal et que j'avais
besoin d'être instruit sur la chose donc
je regrette profondément monsieur Caron
je vous le dis du plus profond de mon
cœur je regrette profondément que nous
n'ayons pas ce débat je suis désolé non
monsieur Caron je suis désolé vous
auriez pu aller au bout laissez
l'assembler débattre peut-être perdre et
remettre après votre ouvrage sur la
table mais au moins on aurait eu le
débat là je suis frustré que nous
n'ayons pas c'est tout ce que je voulais
dire
je vous remercie la parole est à Madame
Pétel pour un rappel au règlement
sur le fondement de l'article 70 madame
la Présidente je vais abonder sur ce que
disent mes collègues je vais abonder
parce que j'allais voter cette PPL
j'allais la voter parce que
j'allais la voter monsieur Corbière
s'il vous plaît chers collègues seul
madame Petel à la parole monsieur
Corbière vous venez de vous exprimer
s'il vous plaît merci bien vouloir
écouter madame Peters
une PPL sur l'abolition de la corrida
contre la vie majoritaire de son propre
groupe vous m'avez ôté cette possibilité
de débattre vous me l'avez ôté
monsieur Caron a découvert monsieur le
rapporteur a découvert qu'il pouvait y
avoir
c'est à peu près ce que fait la France
insoumise depuis le début de cette
mandature
des amendes
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
aujourd'hui nous avions la possibilité
d'avoir un vrai débat démocratique
comment s'appelle le collègues et
peut-être de construire ce que nous
devons faire dans cette émission
c'est-à-dire un compromis des
rapprochements
pouvoir confronter des idées confronter
des points de vue monsieur Caron ce qui
se passe aujourd'hui est exactement
l'attitude que vous avez eu en
commission des lois une telle
condescendance vis-à-vis de vos
contradicteurs que même les indécis ne
se sont pas rangés dans votre camp
mais c'est ça que vous avez réussi à
faire
unir les gens contre vous quand on doit
écrire la loi
quand on doit fabriquer la loi on doit
fabriquer du compromis
et ça vous n'avez pas su le faire je le
regrette je regrette aussi aujourd'hui
que vous ayez choisi d'arrêter la DG la
discussion générale après une prise de
parole de la nupes
moi je suis désolé je ne suis pas député
pour utiliser cette émission
merci comme un plateau de télévision
merci pour l'utiliser merci comme pour
ceux qui l'est c'est à dire la fabrique
de la loi
monsieur de l'épineau pour une demande
de rappel au Règlement sur quel
fondement
[Musique]
sur le fondement de l'article 70
cinquièmement car nous considérons
groupe rassemble un national que que
Monsieur Caron nous a outragé il nous a
outragé puisqu'en fait il a remis en
cause l'essence même du travail
parlementaire en stigmatisant le nombre
d'amendements alors puisqu'on nous
prédit débat de fonds à rappeler que la
corrida concerne des écosystèmes
régionaux importants donc il y avait des
choses à dire ça c'est la première chose
et deuxième chose
l'outrage ne peut dissimuler votre
débandade et votre débandade est
d'autant plus désagréable que je tiens à
rappeler que les uns et les autres dans
cette hémicycle nous avons subi un
véritable harcèlement dans nos boîtes
mails car nous avons été assommés je dis
bien assommer de dizaines et de dizaines
de mails appelant à voter votre
proposition de loi depuis au moins un
mois
autre observation vous avez décidé de
retirer votre proposition après nous
avoir tenu un discours à la tribune
alors que par ailleurs dans votre niche
parlementaire vous aviez un texte
intéressant qui aurait pu concerner le
pouvoir d'achat des Français donc une
fois de plus par dogmatisme vous avez
préféré faire de l'esbroufe et sur le
premier texte de votre niche d'ailleurs
je tiens à remarquer que votre texte a
été dévitalisé au profit d'un amendement
donc une fois de plus c'est une victoire
à la Pyrrhus que vous avez remporté
toujours est-il que la niche
parlementaire et les filles n'a été en
fait qu'un cirque qu'une vaste blague et
il est regrettable que des sujets qui
auraient pu être intéressant et nous
espérons pouvoir aborder peut-être un
jour la réintégration des soignants
puissent être évoqués dans cette
émission
je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]